vous l'avez reconnu et oui c'est bien
lui
karl lagerfeld timide et un peu stressé
le jeune couturier présentait sa
création au concours du secrétariat
international de la laine en janvier
1955 il finira premier ex-aequo avec un
certain yves saint laurent aujourd'hui
lagerfeld fait partie des grands noms de
la haute couture mais dès le début de sa
carrière
le styliste allemand mettait un point
d'honneur à habiller aussi monsieur et
madame tout le monde
karl lagarfeld vous concevez les
vêtements les vêtements pour femmes pour
homme et pour enfants et aussi des sous
vêtements qui pour moi sont des
vêtements tout court et je trouve que
les petits mousses ou est presque
péjoratif car je trouve que dans le sous
vêtement doit être aussi à l'aise que
dans les autres et bêtement à cette
époque lagerfeld mène une carrière de
styliste ans dépendants ils travaillent
dans le monde entier pour une vingtaine
de maisons différentes
fendi chloé mais aussi des marques de
prêt-à-porter général gilles fait jamais
deux fois la même chose à dire je fais
une collection de robes cher une région
d'europe au marché des pull-overs des
maillots de bain mais je ne fais jamais
même dans l'autre pays du foie la même
chose une polyvalence qui contribuent au
succès du couturier et qui plaît aux
marques pour sept fabricants de
vêtements car il était surtout un grand
visionnaire
les bases justement les grands thèmes de
la mode va falloir suivre et qu'ils
regardent également dans les détails
un talent qui le mènera jusqu'à la
maison chanel en 1983 lagerfeld est
nommé directeur artistique de la marque
en parallèle il lance sa propre griffe
de prêt-à-porter à son nom car pour le
créateur
le style n'est pas une question de prix
ceux qui ont envie et des moyens navals
et les robes fait surréel bon d'accord
mais ça n'est plus indispensable pour
être bien habillé aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui envie d'habiller très bien
avec pas beaucoup d'argent du tout est
une question de goût le choix de style
personnel au ces cette philosophie
accompagnera karl lagerfeld tout au long
de sa carrière en 2004 il est le premier
styliste a collaboré avec la marque de
prêt-à-porter suédoise h&m
[Musique]